yes it's true Peter Capaldi is leaving
the role of Doctor Who and he is doing
so at the same time as Steven Moffat
meaning that series 10 will be his last
full series officially his last
appearance will be the Christmas special
following the end of series 10 I don't
know I couldn't find out if Steven
Moffat is writing that Christmas special
or if Chris Chibnall is but in either
way he we now know when he's leaving him
before the insane speculation about
who's gonna take over the part or who
should take over the part it all begins
can I just say I'm really sorry to see
him go I haven't done a Redux re-ranking
of the actors who play doctor since he
came along and I don't know exactly
where he fall but he'd be upper-half
easily I have really enjoyed Peter
Capaldi's time as the doctor I and and
part of that lead came over time his
first series series 8 was a little bit
iffy for me I feel like he didn't really
find his footing until series 9 now
series 8 he was grumpy which I
appreciated
because you know I as much as I loved
Matt Smith I was ready for a different
feel I was ready for a different flavor
I was ready for a little bit less whimsy
a little bit more edge and Capelli
brought that right off the bat but it
didn't quite click for me until series 9
when you know he he started he started
that series playing a guitar riding a
tank in medieval Europe and you know he
had the hoody he had the sign I love the
sonic sunglasses agent he felt like a
rockstar and that and that is that is
what I will think of Capaldi's doctor
eyes he was the rock star doctor and I
really liked it and I wish we could get
more time with it I mean that said as
far as the modern era go
of Doctor Who there isn't a doctor who's
outstay their welcome yet every single
time but they've said okay I'm leaving
I've been law and ultimately that's
probably a good thing it would be worse
if they stuck around and I was like okay
you're done can you go now and you know
maybe it is time for him to go in the
sense that if he stayed much longer
maybe I wouldn't still want him to stay
around and he's leaving me wanting more
he's gonna leave me asking what are you
gonna come back for a multi doctor story
and and that's probably a good thing at
the end of the day I've seen some people
put out there that you know that they
like that it's gonna be like a clean
break Moffat is leaving and when
Chibnall comes in he'll get to cast his
own doctor I don't really feel the same
way I a part of it is that I'm kind of
skeptical about Jim Dahl overall I think
that has to do with just my view on his
output on Doctor Who so far which is not
awful but also not great
to be fair I haven't seen other series
that he has been the showrunner on so
maybe if I saw you know things like I
think it's broadchurch is his maybe if I
saw that I'd have more confidence but I
haven't so I don't so the idea that that
he's coming into to run the whole show
without sort of a stabilizing factor of
a doctor we already know that that makes
me a little bit more nervous I said
before in terms of Moffett levy I think
it is time for him to go I've enjoyed
his tenure I think a lot more than many
Doctor Who fans so far as I'm able to
tell but I do that I do think it's time
for for him to move on and for the show
to bring in somebody else but I I'm just
bummed out guys I mean I'm not I'm not
depressed by it it was inevitable but I
I had taken a lot of comfort in the idea
that you know Moffat had said he was
leaving a while ago but but Capaldi
hadn't said the same thing I and I liked
that and that's not the case anymore so
it just kind of kind of
Meowth I don't have a big overall point
I I don't have a message I'm not going
somewhere with this I just I love Doctor
Who and this announcement came down and
I wanted to get my thoughts out I'm not
sure anyone else could have quite
delivered the line I'm the doctor and
this is my spoon and sold it the way
that he's sold it I hope that they're
not sort of building up to him leaving
as like being a thing for the whole
series I don't want it I don't want the
feel of at the end of an era baked into
all of series 10 I would like a good fun
rollicking time that's what I want out
of series 10 and then you know you can
get his melancholy as you want with the
with the Christmas special when he
actually leaves so I guess that's it
capaldis wrapping up his time I have
enjoyed his time I will miss him and let
the speculation on who's gonna replace
him begin yeah people are gonna be going
nuts and the debates should it be should
they be old to the be young is it time
for a woman is it time for a black
doctors that this is it that I don't I
have general thoughts I don't know if
it's enough to do a separate video on
but I don't look forward to that end of
things the the doctor casting
speculation has never been something
I've particularly enjoyed what are your
thoughts on it do you think it's a good
time for him to go would you have liked
to have gotten more series on them do
you like the doctor leaving at the same
time as the showrunner does is that
something that works for you it yes no
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe hit that little Bell so you
get notifications when I put new stuff
up follow me on Twitter right council of
geeks check out the council of geeks
podcast available on iTunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned